as to the circumstances in which she met
her death
as has no doubt been explained to you by
your Council
the only sentence which the court can
impose for murder is one of life
imprisonment
but I am required to fix a minimum term
which you must serve in any event before
you would be eligible to be considered
for parole
whether or not he will be released at
the end of the minimum term
will depend on The View taken by the
parole board at that time
as to whether you continue to represent
a danger to other members of the public
I am in no doubt whatsoever
and your Council realistically
acknowledges it that this was a murder
done for gain and as such Pursuits
schedule 21 of the sentencing Act 2020.
the starting point must be one of 30
years imprisonment
figure which Falls to be adjusted
according to the mitigating and
aggravating features of the case
which is a topic to which I shall return
you are now 38 years of age
you have one minor previous conviction
for breach of a non-molestation order
which arose in a domestic context
I propose to ignore that and to treat
you as a woman of effective previous
good character
you are clearly a highly intelligent
woman
having obtained first-class honors in
2006 in human Sciences from King's
College London
and then gone on to qualify as an
osteopor
you went to live and work in that
capacity in Australia
returning to live here with your mother
in 2015.
you live together in a large property in
North London and the two of you decided
to add an upper floor to the house
this proved to be your undoing
you and your mother paid a total of 230
000 pounds
to two builders
one of whom evidently cheated you
and you were thereby exhausted of a
large part of your resources
but the work remained substantially
unfinished and the house was left
without a roof and covered in
scaffolding
meanwhile
you met the victim in this case through
the church
sometime it would appear in 2020.
she like you was a very devout Christian
and it is clear from the hundreds of
phone messages that passed between you
over a period of several months right up
to the time of her death which featured
in the evidence in the trial that you
became very close
she was 67 years of age
and of Malaysian origin
she was a woman of some means and the
evidence showed that she was extremely
generous
unfortunately she had a history of
serious mental illness
having been diagnosed some years ago
with paranoid schizophrenia
and she had spent some months as an
inpatient at a mental hospital
shortly before you killed her she had
suffered a relapse
and against her will had been put on an
antipsychotic medication
as such
and as he well knew she was particularly
vulnerable
both mentally as well as physically
and the jury saw from the CCTV evidence
how in the days before her death
she walked with difficulty
needing to hold on to the arm of her
lodger as she did so
the messages that pass between the two
of you
showed that she was very well aware of
your problems with regards to the health
and was proactive in attempting to help
you
this culminated in her offerings give
you
two hundred thousand pounds to spend on
the house
an offer however
which he withdrew a few days before you
killed her
which I am sure is what led you to do
what you did
on the morning of the 11th of June of
last year
you've set off early from your home
address
taking with you a large suitcase
which was evident from the CCTV
was either empty or had very little in
it
you went by public transport to her
address and you stayed there for over
five hours
when you emerged from the property
it was clear from the CCTV evidence that
you had injured your hand
I'm satisfied that can only have
happened
whilst you were inside the house
and must have occurred in the course of
The Killing
later that evening you attended Saint
Thomas's Hospital
where you were treated for a fractured
finger
you claimed that had occurred when you
trapped it in a car door
in my judgment that was clearly a lie
a suitcase that you had taken to the
house
was now
very obviously full and heavy
you also now had with you another case
I'm sure that this other case was the
one that the police later recovered from
your home
it is clear that it belonged to Deborah
Chong
and it contained many documents that
also belonged to her
including her passport
driving license naturalization papers
Bank credit and other Loyalty cards
that large suitcase contained Deborah
Chong's body
I have no doubt that you had killed her
whilst you were at her house
and absent any explanation from you
given that you weren't no comment
throughout your police interviews and
did not go into the witness box
I am driven to the conclusion
that you went to her house that morning
with that intention in mind
two weeks later
you hired a car
for a period of only 24 hours
you were seen on CCTV
to put that large suitcase into the
higher car
it was clearly heavy
such that you needed a trolley to wheel
it down the road and into the car
that is because it contained Deborah's
body
you then drove down to Devon
where you clearly plan to dump her body
that your plans went awry
when you had a puncture
which had to be attended to by the AAA
this meant that you had rather less time
down there
find a place to secrete the body then
you had envisaged
hence why you were unable to find a more
remote location than you did
the place that you were lighted upon was
at the bottom of some steps on a public
footpath
by some Woodland
adjacent to Bennett Road in Sulkin
a truly telling piece of evidence
against you
was the fact that that evening
after the punch of Tire had been
repaired
your hire car was seen being driven by
you
on Bennett Road
15 meters away
from where Deborah's body was found the
following afternoon
by a lady who was out walking
that Grim Discovery was made all the
worse
by the fact that her head had been cut
off
it was not found until the number of
days later
some 10 meters away from the body
further down the hill beneath some
undergrowth
because of the extent of decomposition
of the body
Pathologists who carried out the autopsy
was unable to ascertain the cause of
death
but what was found was that she had
suffered a combinated fracture to the
skull as well as multiple rib fractures
as part of your degree
you were taught Anatomy
when you include it on your website
which advertised your services as an
Osteopath
the fact that you had experience in the
dissection of human bodies
that no doubt stood you in good stead
when you cut off Deborah's head
although why you chose to do that
remains a mystery
following your arrest on the 6th of July
amongst the items found by the police at
your home
was a will
which purported to be that of Deborah
and to leave 95 of her assets to you
and the remaining five percent to your
mother
that Will was fake
it was written by you
and it contains signatures of Deborah
and two witnesses
Each of which had been forged by you
one of the persons whose signatures you
forged
is that there's a man by the name of
virtual Gail Gita
an earthworm neighbor of yours who had
died some months earlier
following his death
you had managed to gain access to his
room
and you took from that room
various papers of his
including his passport
as well as his mobile phone
a short time later you rang the phone
company
tending to be him
giving his name and date birth and you
had the phone reactivated
it was his phone rather than yours
that you used to book the higher clock
and it was his phone
that you took with you on the trip to
Devon leaving your own at home
moreover
the evidence of the handwriting expert
was that his purported signature on the
will
had been copied from his passport
which you had removed
from his room
quite apart from anything else I am
driven to the conclusion
that you are extremely devious
I said at the outset of these remarks
that I would return
to the issue of mitigating and
aggravating features
the soul mitigation is that you are
effectively a woman of previous good
character
although given
the gravity of your crime
in my judgment that entitles you to only
a very modest discount
has to aggravating features
there are the following
firstly
the
amount of planning and
premeditation that went into this
offense
although it is right to acknowledge
that this is bound to be an invariable
feature of a killing done for gay
and I must avoid double Counting in that
regard
secondly there is the issue of Deborah's
mental and physical vulnerability
to which I have already referred
and of which you were very well aware
thirdly there is the chilling aspect of
what you did to and with her body after
you had killed her
you have shown absolutely no remorse but
it appears that you are in complete
denial as to what you did
notwithstanding what in my judgment
amounted to overwhelming evidence
against you
the enormity of your crime
is profoundly shocking
even more so
given your apparent religious devotion
as well as the fact that Deborah Chong
was a good friend to you and had shown
you great kindness
the sentence of the court is one of life
imprisonment
and the minimum term of imprisonment
that you will in any event be required
to serve will be 34 years
there will be deducted from that term
the 475 days that you were spent in
custody on remand
and the statutory surcharge
fly
could you please take the defendant
downstairs